most of trumps pronouncements even the
ones that have been restrictive have
been guidelines without penalties most
of the penalties and most of the
punishment mostly absolute shut down the
economy came from governors so even
though I did devolve the states the
states will draconian my state including
my mic my governors are you know just i
calling DWP drunk with power can you
talk a little bit about your
relationship with Trump because one of
the things that I've said to my audience
repeatedly is first off I should tell
you you'll appreciate this I voted for
Gary Johnson I'm here in California and
I had the luxury of you know doing a
third party situation which obviously
certain people depending on where you
live you didn't have the luxury of doing
that but I wanted to make a vote for
liberty more than anything else but one
of the reasons that I've become more
okay with Trump over the last couple
years is that the guy that I respect
most in the Senate you has become one of
his big allies and my feeling was well
if Rand Paul who I aligned with on so
much of the Liberty stuff sees something
in him that he can work with then I view
that as a net good can you talk about I
a little bit about your relationship
personally but also just what do you
think his actual governing principles
are because it's hard to say they're
traditionally conservative or Republican
or whatever else he doesn't come from a
steeped developed generosity of
libertarianism however when you talk to
him about warm and he talks about the
Iraq war he gets it more than any other
Republican obviously other than my dad
or myself or Mike Lee he gets it and he
says the Iraq war was a mistake he was
unafraid to criticize the bushes for
making what he said was the biggest
foreign policy blunder over the last few
decades and he's right about that and if
you talk to him he'll tell you
consistently wants to bring the troops
home from Afghanistan he wants to end
the war but here's the problem is it is
a tug of war I try to influence and
really I don't think you can change
people I think you can tug at their
instincts and try to bring them in a
direction they may already believe in
and I think he already does believe
those things the hard part is
been surrounded off and and many of his
appointees have been people with
opposite opinion of ours but also
opposite opinion the president's john
bolton was a disaster john bolton sort
of is the antithesis of libertarianism
you know he's a big spending hog and
never met a war he didn't like and never
met a simple civil liberty who wouldn't
trample and yet he got picked and was on
the inside but he was there every day
and i'm talking to the president once a
week so i'm at a disadvantage
lindsey graham's on that same side as
well so we you know he's pushing one way
we were pushing the other but i can tell
you in private when it's the president i
and lindsey graham he'll often rebuke if
not always rebuke graham for being for
so much war and being for a perpetual
war all that being said libertarians
limited government people people want
less war who are conservatives all get
frustrated it's like how can we got
about the same amount of troops we got
more troops in Saudi Arabia but also
look at it this way it's always a
balance of how of what it could be so
for example the conflict with Iran had
you had Lindsey Graham as president
during that and we would have blown up
Iran we would have had a whole war we
may well have had regime change and
people say ought to be good well but it
could be chaos and it could be another
10 or 15 years of chaos in that region
so I think the President does show
restraint you know they shot a drone
down you know of course they said they
didn't but I mean all evidence pointing
to us I'm shooting a drone down and the
president showed restraint
he said well nobody was killed and the
they were encouraging me everybody
wanted me to attack around it was gonna
be limited but we're gonna kill
I don't know 150 or 450 or something he
just said you know we're just not gonna
do it and I think there's a great
there's statesmanship and restraint and
I think he shows that I think his
instincts are good on war and I think
libertarians who decide you know I want
to effect the election I might as a
battleground state
I think should look for things like that
is he a perfect libertarian now he
doesn't seem to be too concerned with
dad or really the size and scope of
government as much as many of us would
wish but on war he has some instincts
towards less war less intervention on
money we spend overseas and
international agencies and all the stuff
where we give
our sovereignty and these international
agencies you know blast us and and
harangue us and tell us how evil we are
while cashing our checks that pays for
all that their salaries
he's very good on understanding that and
thinking that other people need to pay
their fair share and so there's a lot to
be said that's good and then you know it
is always we're all you know I tell
people if you want the perfect candidate
run for office yourself if otherwise
they're always picking and choosing and
trying to find the best that you can
find yeah so all right let's shift a
little bit towards Corona and stimulus
and just what's happening broadly I'm
finding right now that there actually is
a really nice moment for liberty minded
people because one of the things that
we're suddenly talking about in America
that we never talked about or when I go
to libertarian conferences they talk
about it but nobody else talks about it
it states rights that is actually
something being discussed at a national
level right now I think people are
realizing they should be able to protect
their family so talking about the Second
Amendment I think people are realizing
that maybe they don't want to be in
giant cities anymore in I sense we're
gonna have some really interesting
population things changing do you sense
that because of coronavirus that the the
Liberty movement and people realizing
that your your congressman and your
senator are way more important or should
be way more important to your life than
your president or are you hopeful that
something might crack here I mean I'm
even seeing lefties say we should lower
taxes on people now because they need
more money in their pockets well you're
optimistic and I'm glad you're
optimistic on it I would say this I
would say one of the lessons we can and
should learn from the way government
responds to this virus is that one size
doesn't fit all and that would go along
with federalism and that will go along
with really you should try to devolve to
the smallest governmental unit and
really beyond that you know the ninth
amendment says the rights not listed or
not to be disparage but they're to be
left to the states and the people it's
important it's not just state
governments because state governments
can be tyrannical as well we're really
and the people the problem we have is
even though we have devolved most of
them most
Trump's pronouncements even the ones
that have been restrictive have been
guidelines without penalties most of the
penalties and most of the punishment
mostly absolute shut down the economy
came from governor's so even though I
did devolve the state's the states with
draconian my state included my mic my
governor's you know just I calling DWP
drunk with power the guys intoxicated
with his own power but here's what
happened in our state the legislature
who knows when years ago passed an
emergency action bill and said the
governor gets it during an emergency and
I think he even gets to declare the
emergency well you know there's no
check-in balance our legislature can't
call themselves back in session we have
a majority republican legislature they
have no say
the governor has become essentially the
sole and unique and all-powerful person
that dictates everything about the
economy he closed everything down and
he's still saying things like well we're
not gonna have childcare open up until
we get a vaccine it's like really
so working parents aren't going back
what if we never get a vaccine he banned
church he banned to interstate travel
the court struck him down on both of
those but he keeps on going and he acts
as if he's you know he's really out
there to try to help save the people
we've had a little bit over 300 deaths
and that's sad if it was somebody in
your family but that really the number
of deaths in Kentucky closely mirrored
the flu from before I'm not saying this
is the traditional clue but I am saying
in certain states the outcome has not
been worse than the flu the other thing
about one-size-fits-all that we need to
recognize is young people have almost a
zero mortality to this zero to 18 almost
zero less than the flu they don't want
to hear it but 0 to 18 deaths among
children is less than the flu flu is
more deadly now if it goes up it's the
opposite when you get to 70 and 80
particular if you're 80 and above and
you are in a nursing home it might be 20
or 25 percent mortality which is you
know 50 times worse than the flu so but
that means maybe we should have a
different strategy for the kids to hang
out for who the elderly and maybe we
didn't have to close the economy down
maybe we could have done what Sweden did
and not close the schools down we have
still have knuckleheads like my god
who wanted to keep schools closed in the
fall it's a disaster the economy can't
function many people work with their
kids in school that's where their kids
go to you know it's it's a form of a
place for kids to go while the parents
work and so we've got to open the
schools but that's the biggest thing we
have to do and you're right some of it
devolves back to States and we shouldn't
want more but really we shouldn't stop
the devolution of power with the
governor we got to go to the cities
mayors and really ultimately if you own
your business it's your business and
you're gonna have to respond to public
pressure I don't have to tell you what
to do if you run a risk and you say I'm
gonna do nothing you're gonna get some
people like me who have already had it
would love to come to your restaurant
but a lot of people gonna be worried
you're gonna have to do other things you
may have to have a senior citizens
section you may have to have some
spacing but if the government mandates
it they'll be idiots they'll tell
everybody is six six week apart and if
I've got five kids I don't need to
socially distance for my kids we should
all sit at one table on top of each
other you know but if the government
mandates it they're gonna do ridiculous
things businesses will figure this out
churches will figure this out
you know if your mother's 85 years old
and she lives in a little small town and
20 people go to her church and they'll
you know spaced out in the church since
she wants to go
by golly let her go but if your mother's
85 years old and she used to a mega
church with 2,000 people crammed into
the pews I wouldn't mandate that she not
go but if she were my mother I would
tell her not to go mean so we're not
stupid we should let people make
decisions on risk if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell